a tratando de sobrevivir a esta la
primera jornada tras una votación
dramática que si lo mantiene frente a
downing street- pero ha dejado a su
gobierno muy debilitado
johnson se ha reunido esta mañana con
los ministros del gabinete para decirles
que está listo para trazar una línea
después de esa polémica pero no
necesariamente es lo que va a ocurrir
porque como les digo su gobierno está
viviendo una crisis no hay autoridad ni
credibilidad en el primer ministro y eso
en el futuro inmediato significa que va
a tener muchos problemas de
gobernabilidad de aprobar leyes el
resultado de las últimas horas demuestra
que el partido conservador del que
johnson el líder tiene muchísima más
división de lo que había sido evidente
148 diputados votaron para que pueda
llegar un nuevo líder es decir que no
quieren que johnson siga al frente del
partido lo que significa que es un
panorama oscuro para johnson si se tiene
en cuenta que en el 2019 arrasó en las
elecciones generales johnson ha
insistido en que es hora de que el país
trazó una línea después de esta pole del
partido pero eso no va a suceder en el
inmediato plazo porque el parlamento
todavía lo va a investigar para
establecer si mintió deliberadamente
sobre este escándalo hoy figuras
importantes de su partido del partido y
partido conservador han dicho que la
salida de johnson es apenas cuestión de
tiempo